Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: Dr. Bright is Not Allowed
to Kick SCP-2558-J!
SCP-2558-J refers to a group of seemingly
ordinary kittens, who display friendly and
affectionate behavior toward humans and each
other.
When startled or made to feel afraid, the
kittens inflate into a fluffy spherical shape
about the size of a soccer ball, able to move
around by rolling.
Dr. Bright is not permitted to kick any of
the kittens, whether they are in their ball
form or not.
He is also strictly prohibited from playing
dodgeball, volleyball, or any other ball-based
game with SCP-2558-J.
The only way anyone is permitted to play with
the kittens is using the Foundation-sanctioned
cat toys provided upon request.
For crying out loud, man, they're kittens!